Film Courage: If we take novel writing…so
are we going to be spending a lot of detail
on setting a world but if we’re doing a
screenplay how much are we really paying attention
to the where, the setting, the scenes?
Because won’t some of that be fleshed out
when the actual film starts and the director
storyboards or whatever?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher
and Consultant: Yes, I think it is important
to pay attention to the where of your story
right?
Because every choice that you make in your
screenplay should be a deliberate one.
If you’ve chosen a setting there should
have been some reasoning behind that.
You’re not going to set your love story
about working with incarcerated writers, you’re
not going to set that in a juvenile detention
center.
Film Courage: No.
Naomi: You want it to be in a very specific
type of prison to inform that world.
So I think you should pay attention to the
where.
If we’re talking about the process of actually
conveying that on page.
I think the trick of screenwriting is to be
as concise as possible but as evocative as
possible in those few words.
That’s the trick of conveying it on the
page is being deliberate about your choice
and then conveying it as specifically as possible
so you can get as much out of your choice
as you can.
Does that make sense?
Film Courage: It does, so fade in: If we’re
talking about this hypothetical library how
much am I telling?
Naomi: So early in your screenplay because
you’re just introducing us to the world
of your story you will probably take a little
more time to convey where we are, the feel
and the tone of where we are and maybe the
important characteristics of that setting.
As your script progresses you will probably
need to describe less both because we’ve
probably seen a lot of these locations and
then also because you want your story to move
fast.
So as you go further along in the screenplay,
you’ll probably spend less time establishing
locations then you did in the very beginning
when you were trying to establish the world
and create that world in our minds so we could
live in it for the duration of your story.
Now that said I think that there is also value
in knowing which moments in your screenplay
should breath and when you have a moment that
you sort of need to give space to that might
be when you bring us into the world for a
little bit for a little bit longer for some
extra detail or telling us what is going on
in that scene or something like that.
Does that make sense?
Film Courage: It does.
Is that the same if we’re doing a character
description in the beginning?
If we use this hypothetical librarian [a story
idea mentioned in an earlier part of this
interview], she’s age 35, straight blond
hair, maybe a little dark under the eyes from
staying up all night reading.
Naomi: So there is a lot of emphasis put on
those character introductions right?
I have two minds about this.
I think that people get caught up in writing
like the perfect character introduction.
I think that they are important because the
first time we meet your character we want
to give us a sense of who they are concisely
and evocatively but I’ve seen some character
introductions that are a little too long that
maybe stop the story in order to give us a
lot of information about the character the
moment we meet them which if you’re reading
a script it can really pull you out if you
are forced to stop the scene and meet this
person.
That feels like it interrupts the flow of
the story right.
I think the trick of writing character introduction
again is the same with all screenwriting which
is be as concise as you can but as evocative
as you can and what you’re trying to convey
when you introduce the character is give us
that defining quality about them, that essence
of the character that is going to be important
to the story.
So physical descriptions might not be as useful
to us because the blond hair might never come
into play in the story.
But it might be useful to know that she’s
overworked or that she is burning the midnight
oil or that might be important to the story
and the situation that she finds herself in
so stuff like that could be useful and you
just have to determine what is the most defining
quality about this character that I need my
reader to understand right now as I introduce
them